but I had a huge house and all my bills
were paid for and I never had to think
how they were going to get paid my grass
was cut well L the last year of
Separation but you know what I mean all
the basic things to keep the image up
and I gave up my entire image that I was
trained to have for my family for 23
years I like how she doesn't even say
she misses her
kids do I
I'm like kids you missed the HS but
she's like I missed the lawn being
mow I missed the image I miss my
chi what up guys welcome to the just cly
things YouTube channel and welcome to my
reaction series before I start don't
forget subscribe to the channel bring
that notification Bell like the video on
your way in today I'm going to be
reacting to a woman who destroyed 23
years of marriage and instantly regret
it let's go be happy and trying not to
cry why okay hear that language me I
want to be happy cuz my ex has so much
money he makes more than $188,000 a
month easily and now I sit here with the
triggers because he's going to the
Clemson Notre Dame game with my kids I
can't just randomly afford that hell I
can't even get them all in the same room
at the same time so I sit here and I'm
going to get through this trigger I'm
suck it a buttercup and a move on but
it's not fair like it's not fair I'm
pissed welcome back
family assass isn't always greener on
the other side it's not today we are
going to review this 47-year-old woman
who decided to leave her 23-year-old
stable marriage in order to find her
happiness and then she had the nerve to
gets mad and jealous at her ex-husband
because he is doing much better
financially after the divorce let me
start by showing how yeah you and it's
funny cuz she's talking about what she
can't afford and look at fake nails look
I don't even have fake nails no I should
but it's like who's got time for that so
one you have to spend the time to go get
them done H it looks like she has Botox
some sort of filler um heavy makeup
blonde hair dye like all of that stuff
is expensive so how do you not have
money but you have all of that done this
woman can victimized herself I mean if
there was a victim Olympics competition
this woman would have strike gold now
before the sweet tears let's watch her
summarize her life story in few minutes
hey it's Chen recently divorced and kind
of figuring out this new way of life I
was married for 23 years and with that
person for 3 years prior so for a total
26 years of my life I have been out of
the game of dating making friends going
out um and see she felt like she missed
out like that as a single woman in her
40s yeah I'm 47 so I've raised children
my children are adult children now and
um it's kind of interesting cuz cuz it's
so lonely at this stage in life life
after divorce especially with older
children cuz you make all your friends
when they're younger or at least I did I
met my friends mostly through my kids
activities I was a stay-at home mom and
I took them to practice now she's last
exercised from our friend group I went
to school all that stuff um during my
marriage my weight went up and down um
my looks fluctuated dependent on health
needs or what a mental state I was in in
because of the abuse I was dealing with
and also just abuse right children and
being exhausted literally doing
everything so as your children get older
and as you I wonder if she worked go
through changes in life like divorce or
anything like that your looks will tend
to change mine have obviously changed a
little bit actually a lot um I have
autoimmune disease so I did not have
control over my weight for many years
she have a dog didn't she say she
couldn't afford anything and once they
got my medication under control and then
I got out of my toxic environment and
honestly I find refuge in the gym I live
in the gym I have always been an athlete
I've always loved to work out so this is
not anything new it's nothing is gy
chicks is sort of a red flag sorry guys
because it's not even because of the gym
itself but because it's like the more
selfish behaviors women do where it's
like about themselves the more selfish
they tend to be um so I found that like
a lot of times gym chicks kind of really
self focused in general CH in like six
months when kind of and kind of ho the
extreme ones I'm Healed I will always be
a gym rat um but it's interesting
because I found that you know with this
new day and age um I've kind of gotten
into Tik toks and all that stuff um and
social media I'm a photographer like
that's part of my job I'm a Visual
Communications major back in the day
everything I do is Visual and so this
was like and she's not really making
money like that not like she thought
thought she'd be most women most women
don't have what it takes to run a
successful business they don't something
I could grasp to I could feel I could
see touch all that stuff I've said a
million times how I don't um connect
online just through text and all that
stuff so it's interesting to me um some
things and I wanted to bring a raise
attention that I have recently come
across and heard a ton um I have had so
many people message comment I've even
had people in my like personal life say
you look expensive or you're really
pretty so she does look expensive it's
because of the nails the all the it
looks like she's had worked done uh the
fake hair probably you know I don't
understand why you would complain about
that like like pretty girls can't have
problems or pretty girls can't feel sad
about anything lots of girls get this
they just the guy just wants to get that
girl's attention someone they've seen on
social media for whatever reason she's a
girl in their town they know they yeah
she has the looks I think this is
projecting most men don't really think
that much about this stuff I I there's a
study done of like men when they like
turn their head and look at a girl on
the street they don't really like think
too much about it after women are the
ones that build up these like fantasies
about men that have this whole story
like I've heard of a chick that did a
whole show about her ex like a TV show
and this guy didn't even know that she
thought they were dating like I met this
girl oh my God she was she was crazy but
H like you don't really hear that with
guys as much yeah whatever the reason is
but they really don't want anything with
that girl they just want the ego boost
the attention for that moment and all
that stuff um and then they move on and
so I've had this happen several times
and um I've said to my girlfriends and
close confidence and I'm like I don't
understand like I don't get it what am I
doing wrong and they're like you're not
doing anything they knew immedi sorry
guys I was up early um you're doing
something wrong and this is the problem
this is why I I always ask women like
why do you lie why can't we just be
honest that you were out of their league
they just wanted you to be the toy they
wanted to you know get you and and play
with this shiny toy that they thought
was so pretty or they thought had all
these attributes that they want they
they just don't see you as wife material
and they don't typically see 47-year-old
single mothers that left their marriage
of 23 years as a risk they're really
trying to take I mean the way guys are
going to see it is you left a marriage
of 23 years what the hell shot in hell
do I have of keeping you if you were
married with children to a man and he
couldn't um but they knew they couldn't
keep you cuz they couldn't you know
you're out of their league no ma'am no
not out of their league pumped and
dumped by Chad you can try to make
yourself feel better by saying that
these men were out of your league but
the truth of the matter is that you
played yourself by leaving your husband
thinking that you could do better look
where you are now this past year has
been the hardest in my life and this
next season of the holiday season just
triggered myself it's going to be really
really really hard I could be on the
ground right now and I bet the husband's
doing better I bet she was a headache
I'm going to cry cuz I wanted to kill
myself last year I was in Parental
alienation through a separation in South
Carolina separation law that my ex used
everything he could to hurt me and the
hottie season was the epitome of hell
because I was a stay-at home moment and
I was the magic of every holiday you
mean that you okay didn't you just say
she did everything pay for anything you
didn't know how good she had it because
I was a stay-at home home and I was the
magic of every holiday you mean that you
had what most women dream to have you
mean that you were a stay-at-home mom
whom husband was working his ass off so
that you can live a blissful life
without having to work and you threw all
of that away for some fantasy guys this
woman had it so good but she blew it
just because she thought that she was
missing onto some magical stuff out
there that might make her happy check it
out I don't know I'm in a different
stage today honestly I literally have
been been having a great week amazing
week and then all of a sudden today my
emotions I had the craziest thoughts and
I wonder does anybody else feel this way
like I feel like I'm in mourning of the
life I thought that I was going to have
and I'm kind of pissed at myself I
stayed in a marriage for 23 years and
built up a family and my ex's career and
and see there that that's narcissism
when they say I built him up that means
they like to take credit for everything
and we literally just got to where it
was supposed to
be everything we dreamed of like owned a
company making you know almost a million
dollars and that was my breaking point
and I left it all like left it all and
I'm not a person that is about money
I've kind of been in mourning of the
like oh my gosh like I gave it all up
everything was
around family so when I chose to leave I
gave it all up like all up I had no clue
that the worst was Yet to Come who in
the comments think that she built up
that business one year of separation and
so it's weird because I find that I just
thought today for a split second and I'm
like what the hell's wrong with you like
what the [__] is wrong with you I
thought I should have just stayed I
should have stayed it wasn't that bad
like you made it 23 years you made 26
total your kids are like college and
one's almost out of high school like you
made it you he was being selfish women
watch a couple Tik toks they think the
grass is greener on the other side and
they go that's what happens it like it
didn't matter at this point they can do
their own separate life and all that you
made it to the point where you guys were
making so much money and you had big
houses and you could do whatever you
want and you can relax and I literally
just called my friend I was like
freaking out cuz like I'm my biggest I'm
the biggest person that keeps in back
like I'm terrified I don't have 401k my
council did not have my back I was so
traumatized when I got out and then
terrorized for the next year that I
couldn't even think straight to help the
people that wanted to help me and the
people I entrusted to help me didn't
help me and there's just timelines that
you can't stop and so it is what it is
and you know I'm 47 years old it's not
like I'm 25 I'm healthy kind of I have
an autoimmune disease which means it's
lifethreatening for the rest of my life
what is it with all these chicks having
autoimmune disease what causes that they
both it's just they both have it things
can change but it's not like I'm an
invalid and can't do anything for myself
but it is terrifying like I could have
stayed I'm so mad that I you know I do
appreciate that she's being honest
because a lot of women won't admit that
they made a mistake what is up with
these filters guys what is up with these
filters this way I could have stayed my
life would have been so much easier I
like how she doesn't miss him misses the
lifestyle he provided this is I'm men
for your marriage guys have just gone
and done whatever I wanted kind of I
mean I say that and then I think as I
say that I'm like but you couldn't it's
like so weird that my brain thinks that
way and I called my girlfriend and I
told her well you want all the
Privileges of being under a man's
Authority but like that that comes with
a lack of freedom I probably should have
just stayed I should have just stayed it
wasn't that bad and she just started
she's like Jenna what are you talking
about like literally and then I just
keep thinking I'm like but I had a huge
house all my bills were paid for and I
never had to think how they were going
to get paid my grass was cut well not
the last year of Separation but you know
what I mean all the basic things to keep
the image up and I gave up my entire
image that I was trained to have for my
family for 23 years like I was I like
how she doesn't even say she misses her
kids do know I'm like kids you missed
the hospital she's like I missed the
lawn being mowed I missed the image I
miss my
chi
all home mom and I made the image of we
were the perfect family I have beautiful
children they were dressed right they
you know did top sports like cheer and
football and went to all that stuff and
I was you know the cheer mom and you
know did all that stuff and then did
photography on the side just to make
money to make ends meet while he built
his career up and long enough to just
give it all up but when it was like
right there and I'm so mad at myself
because I'm not this way I don't think
this way but it is hard to be a single
female when you're 47 when your kids are
out it's not like I have little kids I
always say if I had little kids this
would be not even a question because
that instinct comes in I have to my kids
you know I got little kids I got to get
them up for school I got to get them to
here I got to get them to there I got to
go to work I got to do that I don't have
that I'm literally at home the worst
time of my day is after the gym at night
when the house is quiet and silent and I
just am in my thoughts and it's so hard
like I My Own Boss if I don't go to work
if I get sick nothing happens and my GPH
photography would just crumble and I
love what I do I have a passion for I
love it but I'm in my head like I'm
literally in my head and I'm booking
shoots and I'm doing amazing I'm so
excited but every time I think future or
long run I freak out a lot of women feel
like this because they will be on
benefit this is the future guys a lot of
women will be in roommates you you're
going to see older women living with
each other because they did not get
married or they left their husband
future was right there like it was
solidified like I was comfortable for
the rest of my life maybe not mentally
in my relationship but financially I was
fine and I gave it all up to be happy
now she sees how stupid it was maybe I
should have stayed it was like stable in
every other area but that like is my
mental health really that important and
then my thank you I'm glad she said this
why do we think think our happiness and
our mental health is first that's last
your family is supposed to come first
because typically doing what you were
supposed to do living out your duty and
responsibility to your family will lead
to happiness in the long term me they're
like yes like yes like you're just in
that crazy in between stage and I'm
trying to work through it I'm trying to
work through the process but it's
terrifying it's terrifying to start over
at 47 but it's hard to know you gave
away my ex will probably never make less
than a million dollars every year
starting over wow idiot at 47 you
thought the grass would be greener she
was a housewife married to a millionaire
a multi- I don't know what he makes but
like and she thought she built up the
business basically as if I'm a
20-year-old again and it just doesn't
seem fair and listen to her talk you
don't hear a mature woman you hear this
is why I say women don't age mentally
they're like 16 for Life think that it
was fair for you to leave your husband
of 23 years so that you can go be happy
or whatever that means your your husband
sucked it up and moved on and now he is
doing better than ever before so you
need to woman up and take responsibility
of your actions now it's time for some
sweet tears and more regrets to conclude
today's
story trying to survive this year I'm
going to be honest the random things
that trigger me are the craziest things
I'm sitting in my car literally sitting
in my car trying to pull myself together
because I did what any mom does and I'm
pulled an emergency
drive to my daughter cuz she needed
something and drove an hour cuz she's at
College to drop something can you
imagine if this was your
mom can you imagine the family group
chat they're like mom posted a Tik Tock
again mom are you all right and was just
so thankful that like I could do it for
her and fit her in my schedule and the
littlest thing she said just triggered
me and this is the second time in a week
that my child has triggered me without
even meaning to so we're getting ready
to leave
and she's like well I'll be home because
we're I'm going to be at the Clemson
Notre Dame game cuz Dad's going to take
us all you think that's nothing right
like nothing right and it instantly like
she instantly saw a switch in me and
she's like what's wrong and I'm like
nothing cuz jealousy control your
emotions chica that's what you do with
your mature smile through it and you
don't let your daughter deal with your
trauma and your animosity and jealousy
that's all that's jealousy I don't talk
about that stuff I don't want her to
worry she's like Mom what's wrong I was
like nothing and I had to keep it
together cuz last week she said randomly
I was like what are we going to do for
Thanksgiving this is my year to have
Thanksgiving with you guys what do you
guys want to do you want to volunteer do
you want me to just cook at home do you
want to go out to eat like I'm literally
like begging for them to give me any
feedback because last year my ex used
every single holiday even if it was my
holiday to be with my kids to isolate me
manipulate them to torment me and
everything he could with the South
Carolina one year of separation law and
I doubt it there's more to the story
lawyer did nothing to help me and the
laws did nothing to help me and my
children were I doubt it it's pretty
easy in Most states to get custody as a
woman she's probably bat [__] crazy
weapons so last week she says oh well
Dad said for Christmas we're going to go
to Gatlinburg and be there for the
holidays and do
Dollywood that man never once ever went
to gatlenburg or Dollywood ever in his
entire life before he met me that was
where my family always went that is I'm
from ten yeah you showed him a cool area
now he's going back that's something we
always did it was a bonding thing and
now that's what he's trying to do it's
like he's taken every single tradition
I've ever done and now turned it into
his I mean if you went to the same place
for 20 years I think he probably just
thinks it's easier everything I've ever
done and the worst part and the thing
that triggers me is that I was screwed
like I'm not even going to lie there's
no way to lie about it like I literally
was screwed now I found myself triggered
because during the hardest time of my
year last year of me literally trying to
stay alive me dealing with all the
craziness of my ex the lying the
alienation him calling me a [__] him
having my children call me a [__] well
why why did they call you a [__] not
because I did anything bad because I
wore spaghetti straps and all that what
what's his side of that story only way
sounds like there's something missing
what do you think the other side is yeah
she cheated that's what I think way that
he could use my children against me was
I bet you the adult kids just don't like
her I bet you she's been crazy for years
I was on social media and some against
me was to say I was on social media yeah
I can't imagine this is like great for
the kids I'm just like King can you
imagine this you're just scrolling on
Tik Tok and you see your mom
I I'm not even helping myself because my
brain is so stressed I'm just trying to
like don't don't keep do how old is she
mentally do you think 12 I gave her
16 I keep tell don't you think oh okay
so 12 just survive right now just get
through it just get through the Hol
dayss but there's a timeline and if I
don't do stuff by February 8th I can
never fix the situation but if I don't
survive
now I'm literally going to be complete
mess mentally so I'm TR like this is
like crazy medium and I'm trying to be
happy and and show my kids that like
life can move on but the triggers the
random [__] triggers I had me sitting
in a quick trip parking lot trying not
to cry why has so much money he makes
more than $188,000 a month easily or at
least he did he made almost a million
his pocket watch I bet she thought she
could get a good payout and it didn't
work out the year before we divorced and
but what does it matter if you're not
with him you're not entitled to it you
wanted to be by yourself so be by
yourself you're not entitled to his
money and I'm really tired of Housewives
saying they deserve the guy's money
because I mean Housewives a housewife is
like minimum wage work sorry guys sorry
don't shoot the messenger watching kids
15 bucks an hour um cleaning the house
like 15 bucks an hour it's really not a
lot of money it's really not um so if
your skills were so valuable then I mean
go I mean you could be a housekeeper
with those skills but again a lot of
Housewives have done nothing for 20
years that's why I say the modern
housewife wants to be pampered she
doesn't want to serve and that's the
problem is I bet you she got out of this
relationship she doesn't realize how
much of a useless parasite she is no
offense check if you see this um because
you know most women are are just doing
nothing for their days about it he has
all the money in his fingertips to do
whatever he wants buy my children take
them on trips he earned it and you would
have been a part of it if you did he's
probably so happy to be divorced I swear
some guys it's like when the woman
leaves they're like thank God because
they're they're better people than us
usually so they'll do the right thing
even if they don't want to but then the
women leave and the men are like Praise
Jesus that woman was Crazy Praise Jesus
they they they're like thanking God
vacations why I literally had the bare
minimum to pay my bills on top of trying
to restart a career because it was a
hobby because I was
stay I know said the same thing King
King is saying guys that she has her
nails and her hair done yeah and also it
looks like she's had work done it looks
like she's got filler Botox and just
like he said I wasn't part of the
equation I was not part of the equation
in entire marriage this man told me my
role in life was to be the mother of his
children and to um do lady I've built
this YouTube career in like two three
years if you really want to get skilled
at something you you could really focus
on one thing and get really good at it
in a couple of years you absolutely can
luckily nowadays you can even freelance
um you could learn to be a video editor
you like the Social Media stuff
obviously um you can you can freelance
and you can figure out a way to do it
that way nobody can turn you down for
being too old anything that was needed
for the family why he built his career I
was not part of the equation so how was
that marriage ever supposed to survive
when I was fully 100% in how can you be
100% in if you left trying to make a
marriage a life a family and this man
never include me in the equation cuz
you're supposed to stay I I feel like
they should pay me for this I'm giving
them all the right answers then when it
was done and I got loose and I tried to
survive that man had been plotting for
over a year on how to make my life help
because he had all the money all the
control and now I sit here with the
triggers I bet you she was plotting
[__] trigger because he's going to
the Clemson not damn game with my kids I
can't just randomly afford that probably
with a hotter chick probably a hotter
chick on his arm sor sorry I can't even
get them all in the same room at the
same time I was sit here and I'm isn't
it the consequences of her own act
trigger I'm going suck it a buttercup
and I'm move on but it's not fair like
it's not fair I'm pissed he said how is
she crying in her face asn't moving I
don't know how it's not fair to not get
money you're not entitled to I hate
entitlements I hate entitlements you're
not entitled to anybody's money oh no no
it's not fair and I don't understand how
now you can go be happy now you can go
pursue your career now you can be a free
and empowered and you see how they say
like let's navigate through this new
Journey this new stage it's like they
want to be the like they want to be a
reality show s to God want to be a
reality show they want to be the next
Kim K forced you to get a divorce like a
dating at profile I love to dress cute
but can get dirty no problem I love to
work out hiking whitewater rafting pool
time help each other through this crazy
life and dating you oh no she's talking
about dating your kids out of the
marriage and you got it there is nothing
in life that is worth having that
doesn't require some kind save me from
red flags and dating that's you I mean
how can I save you from yourself help me
dress cute but not [__] just have oh
no I mean like some of these women Tik
Tok replaces their family efforts and
sacrifices life is all about trade-offs
and choices once you make a decision
you're going to have to honor and live
byy it that's it for today's video but
before yeah life is choices and
tradeoffs all right life is choices and
trade-offs and these women want to make
the choice and don't want to deal with
the trade-off um I'm happy she's being
honest about how much her life sucks
hopefully it'll deter some other women
on Tik Tok that might just get a funny
little idea but guys let me know what
you think in the comments um like the
video on your way out subscribe to the
channel I'll talk to you next time